positivity and involvement through
athletics mary jane belliesa shares how
the north las vegas fire and police
department are giving back to the
community through sports
it's a packed house at sea strand park
in north las vegas as local officials
prepare their teams to play the field
andrew bigger is a firefighter in north
las vegas and now the head coach of the
robots youth soccer team he says
volunteering a few hours of his time is
the department's way of giving back to
the community so now that we have this
kind of opportunity where we can come
out kind of interact with the kids kind
of teach them good you know life skills
good habits teach them soccer you know
help them have fun it's a huge you know
opportunity that we you know get to be
out here parent brenda huerta is here
with her daughter julianna she says this
type of involvement is a great way for
kids to learn more about the fire and
police departments in the area all while
making new friends did want her to get
more active she does have younger
siblings but because it is a gap in the
age they're all three years old four
years old and she's seven so i wanted to
at least get a little bit more involved
aj hernandez from the north las vegas
police department coaches the green team
he's looking forward to more
opportunities like this in the future to
get to have an impact and teach kids
hard work discipline and sportsmanship
at a young age
to get to test some of their athletic
abilities is fun
and yeah to play fire you can't ask for
anything better and shari hickman who's
with her son mason says their dedication
doesn't go unnoticed being that they are
busy
with their work
taking time out to come coach some seven
and eight-year-olds takes a lot of
patience as well
so
we appreciate them
on and off the field mary jean valeeza
live local now
north las vegas